and those initial capacity restrictions
and regulations really hurt community
theaters
but a local nonprofit continues to
advocate for the creative workforce
8 news now reporter kristen drummond
joins us live in our newsroom tonight
with more on those efforts
kristin sasha the producers alliance of
southern nevada formed during the
pandemic
members of the nonprofit continue trying
to find ways
to stimulate the creative economy
advocates say the governor lifting the
capacity restrictions
still does not help all small theaters
that must consider
social distancing various independent
theaters are
converted stores around the valley
there's not a lot of space inside and
certain state rules right now impact
shows from happening at the moment
that includes the mandate requiring 25
feet between the performer
and audience now some theaters can
accommodate that along with the new
capacity restrictions to possibly break
even
if not make a small profit but it's
still a challenge
to navigate the restrictions for some of
the smaller black boxes
it's not necessarily going to have any
kind of impact
uh in terms of indoor theater however
there are places like las vegas little
theater which is a larger theater space
and they can socially distance and have
enough of an audience
that it might have some kind of positive
impact the producers alliance of
southern nevada encourages organizations
to work with the arts community
that includes finding large spaces like
a warehouse a ballroom or
park to offer as an option for the
theater groups to use
for now now the producers alliance of
southern nevada sent a letter recently
to clark county commissioners
it highlights potential ways to invest
in the creative community
such as incentivizing developers and
businesses to provide affordable space
for performing arts venues